awesome we're now live on
the internet
mike my hearty you check out that hot
stream there
sweet i'm gonna switch to this
hello friends and welcome to a very
special now playing of quantum break i'm
sam lake and we're watching a quantum
blade
what's up sam
i'm very happy to be here
sam lake is in this video game
he's in televisions we missed the first
one
uh because we weren't allowed to show it
because of hot embargoes i just kicked
something and then the music turned off
that's back um
but uh speaking of embargoes we're
allowed play now where i play act two of
quantum break sweet the time traveling
time wizard video game from the good
folks at remedy we have to stop
apparently
around the time toto's africa plays
but how does that song fit into the game
i mean it fits in every if it fits in
vice city when you're beating up yeah
prostitute it fits in anything right
surely could we could we
could we want to hear the song now that
you mention it
isn't it always playing in our hearts at
all times here we go folks let's jack in
together that's the term we use when
we're playing quantum break uh we're
playing on the xbox one
version
for those who are asking i have not had
access to the pc version as of yet so
boom uh
if you watch the last
time we streamed this
then you watched the 25 minutes of video
that we enjoyed mike that was great
wasn't it yeah just got some tv in
before uh the rest of the work day yeah
it was that was a long let's talk about
the dry dock incident uh-oh monarch
operatives transported you from the
university to the ground zero operation
at the shipyard i remember this said
about that huh
you were secured unconscious well
uh
will's dead or presumed dead or i don't
know
alive liam burke went to retrieve you i
think he's dead you were gone
how i'm sleepwalking
step away time sleepwalking surprised
they don't just straight up say
previously on quantum breaks yeah kinda
better reflexes
the game literally asks you do you want
to go back to the menu after the first
act as if it's like you've probably had
enough
it's like those nintendo warnings say
you've been playing for quite a while
make sure you've got your wrist drop on
so you may remember when we watched the
cutscene that they were standing there
and then suddenly their guns disappeared
yeah
ice man all along it was ice man the
whole time
what a jerk move
we know beth wilder assisted you in some
manner
then i'm guessing you know the rest no
hold the trigger because everybody who
saw what you did next
is now dead oh
cold-blooded
oh
that was a rather sharp way for that
cutscene to end but sure he just walks
away as africa by total kicks
and that's the end of our stream folks
oh my goodness if you have any questions
at all make sure to stick them in the
chat we'll keep our eyes on them uh i
have to re-familiarize myself with my
where i was time wizard
how many chapters does this game have
literally went through her uh i don't
know to be completely honest like five
or six or something yeah i've heard what
pete beat in what's
under 10 hours right oh really yeah
right so beth wilder you can ask a
little narrative questions here i can
also look for cronons or crow crow what
are they crotons
croutons
collecting cronon sources allowed to
upgrade just sweet powers this is the
first time we've been able to show this
so here are the upgrades they're
basically split into the various
different
you know time
spells
i'm really holding on to this time
wizard thing
yeah you're nailing it time spells you
know so here's the time dodge one
increased focus maximum focus extra
activation so essentially
there is a rank one two and three of all
of these so they're pretty basic uh the
first ones are only one unlock and then
you can see the cost written in orange
or in the bottom of the screen that's
obviously they scale up from them so one
of the things i notice now i was playing
is these cronon sources are actually way
more common than i was expecting there's
like a bunch of them in yourself like a
dozen in each level
and i wasn't really
finding that many of them so that's a
bit of a problem i'm going to go time
shield
jack will recover from danger faster
while within the time shield radius
actually i wanted that so they're minor
like stat changes yeah they're just it's
just three of them yeah it's literally
that and then that and then that okay uh
or maybe i can actually unlock them
individually yeah i guess i just need to
have more more of the points
uh yeah okay let's go for increased
strength with time stop
i gotta hold down the button because
everything in this game is holding down
the button
here we go
it takes time exactly one of seven found
nice work hello i appreciate your
dedication to the time thing so shooting
is this there you go i've got unlimited
bullets because time wizards uh right
bumper does the time bubble thing which
slows people down and you can
fill them up for the bullets uh time
vision is here
at time dodge is i think it's this one
isn't it yeah and then so i can dodge
with that one and then i can stop time
after i dodge by hitting the left bumper
and then is it b yeah does the time
bubble b for bubble thanks microsoft
he's such a trendy dresser i imagine but
like if you're traveling through time
couldn't he wear anything and he's
trendy
he gets back up yeah he comes back with
a bowler head on [ __ ] what are you
doing
i mean i was just in 1920 chicago and i
was fine no one there gave me [ __ ] for
it
okay you're about to come across what is
one of the
other parts of this game that i was not
expecting but becomes quite ubiquitous
the more you play
uh
here is a destructible object
watch me destruct it
oh look
it made the path
that's almost like something you'd see
in a platforming video game
right
now it just needs jumping and
platforming i know
we're about 15 seconds away from a mic
so don't worry uh yeah so this game has
a lot of like what i would say refer to
as probably temporal
platforming
i coined that phrase myself oh that's
part
so if i see that see if i hold y
video game is like all right there you
go but it only rewinds to like
immediately before you did it
so okay
it's just a three-dimensional breeze
yeah so remember yes in the last video i
did the time bubble thing where i like
there was a cherry picker and i had to i
used like the time bubble on it remember
i just went like stop it from spam yeah
yeah it's kind of the other side of that
okay this stuff apparently develops
quite a bit
interesting
uh yeah i was not expecting a lot of
platforming in this yeah and sansa peter
there's actually quite a bit of it so
yeah
all right here we go
i mean you got to do something when
you're not time murdering people you
know yeah
oh no it's littlefinger
what's the actor's name uh aidan gillen
i think gillian gillan you say he's from
northern ireland yes he's from the north
paul serene he is the couldn't escape
i guess the antagonist the main
antagonist of this story although
part of me wanted to put up he's uh he's
kind of he's good friends with this guy
or at least he was before he got stuck
in time space for 17 years
yes for those asking him we're not
completely sure how many chapters there
are but um i think people in the office
who beat it said it took them under 10
hours
that includes the
tv episodes look at all these people are
meant to be executed
so these are the witnesses who are being
executed because i picked the hardline
choice what do you think the red x means
uh probably means that they're
they're cool they went to see them and
they actually they were kind of okay so
they're like i don't worry about it yeah
x for excellent
you guys are excellent
the grading system here is a little
different than we're used to yeah it
starts with x then goes a b they skip c
and then d you don't want a d
you don't i want it i don't know about
you sometimes you just want a d let's
shoot these guys
uh let me know if it's a bit too loud
might be good
so they're gonna start to flank me
pretty quick
yes they haven't oh god damn it
i'm gonna
i'm gonna time messy oh damn what am i
doing
okay there we go
fine bubble
sucks to be you in about one second
boom
getting used to it like i said the first
time i played this game the movement is
floaty it feels a little bit weird let's
turn down the gameplay just a little
yeah just
but uh you do get used to it pretty
quick i will say weapons feel heavy
yeah just out of this swingy you know
like like this is kind of like it's not
exactly the the sharpest thing i kind of
want to play it on pc to get the
see if it's like a mess and keyboard
yeah
it also that kind of has that weird alan
wake max payne thing where you're
constantly running out of ammo so you're
like picking up new weapons all the time
which i talked a little bit last time
just
i mean it it's that age-old thing in
video games where it makes you pick
different weapons you wouldn't have
picked necessarily but then most of the
weapons in this game are pretty similar
so
keep the variety up
forcing it i guess but yeah but then
they're all just assault weapons right
so okay let's use our time vision
it's not wretched clank
you could throw a disco ball
no
it's so armed and dangerous there's no
shark gun in this game
all right use my time bears watch this
here hey what's up
thought you were shooting me
and then of course the sweet little max
paint three thing
all right that's for will yeah
my roommate played a little bit of max
payne three oddly enough this weekend
okay i think it's on sale or something
on steam
this will be on sale not on a sale in a
sale but on sale for sale there you go
for sale yeah on steam in a couple of
weeks
cool
we've got a early access to it here so
if you're just joining the stream we've
got
another little
embargo stream here where we can show
some of this video game we can show act
two up until the part where toto's
africa plays
i'm not even sure if i'm supposed to be
able to say that probably not really but
i've said it already
well do you know the specific point it
starts playing i actually uh yes kind of
okay
i have to stop i think i have to stop
before todos africa plays
is it like what did they say uh
diegetic or is it like dianetics voice
over or is it like
like is it in the game world the music
that's the song oh i i don't know
actually i think it might be
it's either a cutscene or it's a
or it's an in-game cinematic okay or
it's or yeah or it's live action this
game marries the two look at this guy
looks pretty good what's up jack joyce
what's up jj
i think right they've got me doubting it
jack joyce
any questions from the chat
not yet maybe mainly the length of the
game
um
one of the interesting things i'm
looking forward to seeing right now is
that at the end of chapter one we picked
the hardline
story decision not the pr oh the kid
like murder yeah right we just murdered
a bunch of students filthy [ __ ]
you know freeloading students how dare
they
young millennials
yeah try voting for bernie now
well
the last time i played this game i chose
the
it's pretty this game's pretty pretty as
well yeah i chose the pr version which
actually had me in this part of the game
playing alongside one of the
students
who has since been murdered
like i literally
found her helped her escape and then she
helped me and there was like dialogue
options in fact i helped her in here
and there she is
significantly darker than the path you
originally took yeah so that's kind of
cool
that's like a pretty meaningful decision
i mean she's only witcher for like 20
minutes or something but like that's
still pretty cool
i wonder if i'm with someone else now
you're gonna kill that guy too he's dead
oh no he's jammed his gun maybe i kill
him
yeah here we go i'm going to kill him
and walk around with this guy aren't i
eat it
eat it i got a new shotgun test it out
let's test out this guy in slow motion
ah
yikes that'll do it
let's finish him off
turns out several shotgun blasts
to your chest will murder someone the
shotguns you will need because of the
heavy dudes
oh it's a taxi guy
they're killing everybody
the taxi guy right it's the taxi guy the
taxi guy from the start of the game
which we didn't show because of
embargoes oh okay
man they killed that person real bad is
that the lady
is that a student that's a different
that's a different that's not the
student another dead is that her there
oh no
that's her
at least they had a decency to clean it
up
dead
just because they gave a damn about some
shitty old um yeah so she played so
basically i think the taxi driver has
taken her place
okay that's all right that's pretty cool
a little bit of agency there
gotta see if i can shoot or don't edit
because video games you know you got it
can i take my gun out yeah let me tell
you guys and shoot that dead body come
on i'm serious what about player agency
what
could read all this stuff though see
what i mean lots of reading
optional content the weird thing is it
like goes into like narrative objects
but like i don't want to read all that
so it's just gonna it's gonna change the
story i'm not gonna really gonna know
why look eyedrop bottle contains cronon
i thought that said i dropped battle
that comes later that's embargoed mike
you can't talk about the i drop battle
disregard everything so uh my martin
hatch who is the
the the other guy
the the other evil dude who's using the
eye drops his eye drops contain cronon
so he's also some sort of time wizard
man
hey what's up taxi driver
this is an intense conversation we're
having
yeah i think i know the way do you like
my bluetooth headset do you look really
serious staring at him right now
tell me more
it's really intense
so our eye drops one of like several
methods i'd imagine to getting cronons
yeah you could probably just like eat
them or smoke them
smoke them just mix them with some
cranberry juice
so many ways get to get your medical
cronon card yeah
you take a suppository of chronons
sort of releases over the course of a
day
so many ways it's po chrono patches
all right now can i go on a show yes
sorry just want to see player agency
he said no but i thought he's saying
like no don't make me do it video game
player but actually he was just
responding to this taxi man we can't let
them get away with this we can't i know
that's what we're going to do we're
going to murder them because video game
are all the environments from what
you've seen kind of this urban
industrial landscape from what i've seen
but i've not played much past this point
i intentionally sort of uh
yeah university of the stars this is
sort of uh more of a
dockside area industrial oh look
there's always a dwarf check it out
there's always a wharf he's not a merry
man
not
see that
yeah i'm a time wizard
try to finish that conversation in a
time bubble
doesn't work on it you say you're an
x-men
okay okay
sick man
all right this guy's stoned have you
been taking your cronons yeah he
he odd on
this kind of him existed
driving a cab what does that graffiti
say
it says
phantom phantoms yeah i think you're
right
but with
a government
phantoms
i don't know what's going on here not
mardi gras dia de los muertos yes skull
those are lollipops are awesome
oh
i love video game
graffiti
it is this is just like watergate yeah
nixon was a time traveler
i have never been a time traveler
that famous line we all know
there is another way inside it involves
third-person platforming let's go on an
adventure friends
uh i'm gonna go for a little this
actually reminds me quite a lot of
half-life too i'll be honest
yeah sorry this is very city 17.
so one of the things i've not been doing
because i'm an idiot
even though the game has been telling me
is looking for chronon sources
to rank up your rpg things yeah there's
one
there's one right there
good thing they glow good thing they
glow when i use my time vision i need to
jump up here
nope all right i gotta jump up somewhere
else then i gotta get on that shelf so
maybe maybe there's a way over here
so if you had to choose between this
actor's uh iceman powers or time
traveling powers what would you do time
traveling that's what i would think but
what's ice ice powers are like ice bears
are always weird because it's like it's
never like
actually anything to do with ice it's
using the ice to do something normal
like create an ice bridge yeah he like
surfs along in midair it's awesome yeah
like that's not really ice ice bearers
is like being able to like refrigerate
food
put ice cubes in a
drink
you know
cool down a particularly hot child
on a summer's day like they're kind of
benign powers right there's a sprained
ankle yeah exactly
so like all the ice bears in like movies
are all like oh an ice bullet it's not
like an actual ice bear that's just a
bullet bearer you just coat your fists
in ice so you can punch people harder
exactly or do your what was it you said
some sort of ice
skateboard situation oh yeah like oh no
i [ __ ]
if i need it was some way i could
reverse time in specific situations
here we go
so obviously this is all still part of
the showing you had to use this stuff i
don't know how you wouldn't need those
platforms if you could surf along an ice
wave that's true actually
look at that [ __ ] that's pretty cool
yeah
i'm gonna run across it now i don't know
if i should use my
awesome time bubble power i don't think
i needed it
i think there's windows here skip
gingerly across them exactly
it's not gingery brown hair
now
here we
go knock knock
starting to get a little antsy out there
yeah because i'm a time wizard i get it
i'm gonna pick this thing up
another narrative object
so all that stuff impacts on the
cutscenes i believe
it's jill kerstrom sending an email to
ashton leahy and jill jill kerstrom oh
wait that's herself she sent it to
herself she sees it herself that's weird
i guess that's what you do sometimes
when you send it to the wrong alias
just want to double check she got it i'm
going to read one of these out because
we skipped all of these it's all rumors
and conjecture from what i hear i wasn't
at the university off but there's no way
that joyce took out all those guards
he's just some random guy not a trained
assassin the stories floating around
make it sound like he's shooting laser
beams out of his goddamn [ __ ]
anyway
they got liam burke handing him down
right now so i think it's safe to say
joyce is [ __ ] off the record i hear
paul serena has been investigating a
potential traitor with a monarch
somebody's been accessing all kinds of
confidential information
remember that research that dr amaral
was doing to find a permanent cure for
serene's sickness
this is time sickness rumor has it that
somebody sabotaged a test had to start
over just a few weeks later the uni up
goes sour willing to bet the same person
sabotaged us there keep your eyes peeled
man
men
men
the same men
no no man so now
the question
is raised would you rather be able to uh
have time powers or actually shoot
lasers out of your butt like she said
i'm in control of the laser butt thing
or is it like farts
cyclops powers but but not from your
[ __ ]
no i hate shopping for trousers and that
would just like
increase that like 20-fold unless i'm
like
yeah like exposing my chocolate starfish
while i'm doing it every single time i
don't want to do that either
hey you asked a question yeah for our
sake let's let's stick with the time
yeah
time for us is way better
i mean what can't i do
with time bearers that i couldn't that
i'd i could do time versus that's why
this game is about time powers that is
the reason
why sam lake and the folks at remedy
didn't make this game about jack joyce
firing lasers out of his [ __ ]
because that would not be as cool as
what he's doing here for instance watch
this i'm going to murder these guys so
hard because they're all standing
together like a bunch of goobers
i think your gun just wasn't showing up
for a second it looks like he was just
doing like a finger gun thing
oh really i have dreams like that all
the time where that's like watch this
watch just watch it i can charge the
[ __ ] go
eat it how is that
i don't even need to charge up chronons
in his yeah or something
like
ejaculate
oh look at the paint i like that
i'll murder you while you stand there
none of you are taking cover very well
okay i'll do it again they got
bulletproof vests that's good
they seem to think it would stop all the
bullets though what if he shot you in
the face
they got full of food masks on as well
these guys don't these guys are just
regular homies
okay watch this here we go here we go
charge it up
boom
get that sweet time slow down thing
it's a favorite of mine it's all the
time effects that are in the game is
what i like a lot dot and kicking around
bodies that's fun it's always fun
video games that looks like video games
the weapon swap icon is just like the
retweet logo
the little oh yeah a little corner thing
yeah you're right
you can favorite that weapon that's the
eventuality of all media is that we just
put like little snapchat re-snap or
whatever or little
favorite icons of like burst confetti on
everything like if google glass didn't
crash i imagine that's what you would
see next to things
just on your desk well thank god it
crashed
where am i supposed to go probably this
way right
any cronons around here oh yeah good
point thank you mike yeah you're away
right i've been thinking oh i should go
that way okay but you're right i'm gonna
go in the last room and check for some
cronons
this graffiti is impressive just what
was that it looked like a minion from
the other really yeah now well that is
the eventual island that's the most meme
thing you can think of where's the
minion right here
yeah it looks like a minion if drawn by
someone who'd never seen a minion before
based their drawing on a description
from someone who was drunk and never
seen minions
and they themselves were drunk when they
did it yeah
exactly
he keeps doing that uh oh okay so this
is why you need the shotgun
because these guys
can take a couple of shots
it's fair to say
all right let's can i get my
yeah let's do my yeah i've got one
bullet left damn it
oh no i gotta swap
can you do that chrono charge on him
i can but i prefer doing this yeah
yeah
murder
all right let's see where everyone is oh
you're right a red barrel idiot it's
almost as if that power just turns every
weapon into a shotgun because they'll
hit him at once yeah kind of actually
right yeah
kind of makes the shotgun redundant a
little bit uh it's really powerful
though but i shouldn't have used all my
ammo doing shooting one random guy
earlier in the game
let's shoot that thing
see what happens so one of the uh
sort of interesting
i don't know if it's an oversight it's
probably an oversight you can't blind
fire at all
so i'm right triggering here and i can't
blind fire and you can't crouch unless
you're uncovered exactly and you can't
crouch unless you're in cover so the
only alternative to
to like having some sort of if i step
away from this if like somebody comes
around that corner i have to and like i
i want to shoot them i can't just shoot
them crouched i need to stand so if
there's a guy like coming at me here and
there's a guy coming at me here like
some sort of idiot i need to
i have to stand up and expose myself to
shoot that guy yikes so it's not really
much of a problem right now in the early
stages but later on when you start to
get like
flanked by a lot of people very quickly
that becomes an issue and maybe that's
the game trying to tell you
yo don't put yourself in situations
where you need to
where you're like
i don't know having a load of people
swarming you like jump around a lot more
yeah but it is a bit of a bit of an
issue i wonder if it's yeah trying to
get you to rely on the time powers but
it would have been helpful earlier with
that heavily armored guy with a shotgun
just blind firing right over it oh
totally right that's like your go-to
that's what you think straight away when
you're when you're in a situation like
this oh look that guy there look he's
standing right beside this one idiot
that's pretty cool
he went for a time
trip
time trip let's get out of here
shotgunner advancing thanks for
telegraphing that appreciate it i wrote
down a bunch of time puns i looked at my
desk did you yeah idiot i forgot
wrong going to be doing this with
it's right there it is
oh
case in point cut couldn't blind fire
there a little bit annoying but would
you play like just cause three enough
you kind of get used to the idea of
tethering explosive barrels to people
yes
that was a good point that that uh like
habit almost kicked in just now that's
wondering why you weren't doing that
and one of the other things well we've
turned off the um
the oh i'm gonna use my time
charge thing there on that guy didn't
kill him
we're gonna come across a lot more of
these guys soon uh well yeah one of the
things we turned off in the last the
last time we played this was the
auto aim which is on by default so if
you're wondering why i'm snapping up and
not connecting with people that's why
okay do you usually do that in shooters
it's just like it's a little bit i mean
they give you the reticle on this right
so it shouldn't be too hard so like if
i'm aiming there it's like yeah so it's
fine
but yeah it's a
little bit more frantic here
that's what keeps happening is that like
i'll i'll when they're in motion i'll
connect with them but then they're
they're moving so
i can't shoot through those at all or at
least not very effectively
11 rounds left
you see the last one
yeah that you are going through ammo
pretty fast
you know what i mean yeah i was talking
about about like flicking between
the various guns quite a lot oh hello
boom boom boom boom boom look at the
death in his
eyes delicious in the life leaving them
all right
all right taxi guy
alternatively all right
student
leading
how would you know that
taxi person
is there a regular melee outside of the
time badge thing
i do not know
actually i don't think so
this is me hitting every button on the
controller i guess you wouldn't really
need to like pistol swipe if you could
just
time rush at someone i mean if you could
like slow down time and then actually
okay and body slam them this is one of
my favorite parts
all the stuff about the actual like
manipulating time
the like animations they do are so cool
look at this
that's pretty cool cool
act so one of those is a really amazing
one which they've shown before
uh it's about to come up it's gonna come
up in like the next little while
have you seen eternal sunshine of this
box
reminds me of that when they're going
through his memories yeah taking that
he's trying to hold on to him
that is a great movie yeah whoa
the ultrasound back was there on there
there was
i think maybe maybe there was future
croutons
wait so did you just go into the past or
something whoa in this room i think so
okay
oh yeah it all happened again behind me
trippy
i just gotta jump out
time to cross the sky bridge man that
sky bridge in the sky
the old sky bridge we all end up at
time sky bridge run
why is there no cover anywhere here
okay okay this is the exact situation i
was talking about earlier yeah
i got to stand up to kill this oh now
the guys on your right can shoot whoa
that's why time slow down
i'll take that one sure no worries oh
wait no i can't
oh so one of the things they're probably
going to introduce intro joyce now i
almost said injure joyce
wow uh unintentional fun unintentional
oh die
is the
is that i'm gonna have to fight some
other time wizards
yeah okay
that's where the game seems most
appealing to me is when
powers are working against each other
yeah makes you think a bit more
laterally than you would in like these
situations right look at that lighting
this game looks pretty when it wants it
for those asking this is the xbox one
version yes and uh we mentioned it a
little bit before but besides no blind
fire you were saying the gun play feels
pretty floaty
yeah it's uh
oh that probably didn't work out very
well
damn it
maybe not maybe not so much the shooting
as much as the movement okay just the
movement in general the movement of
jack's character
the movement of
boom at least you can shoot through that
i-beam
yeah right i know it's pretty good
the movement of his character and thus
the movement of the shooting but like
not necessarily like just because of him
like it feels like he is the object that
is sort of weighing down my uh my
ability to move around whoa that was
pretty cool
that guy
yeah so it just feels like
this is me moving the left stick
right and i can put up the sensitivity
on that but like most of this game is
spent doing this
so you don't want it too high because
then you're you know you're shooting
people at quite quite a large distance
or at least ideally that's what you're
doing
because that's what you do in video
games yeah okay so let me see so like
i'm going to pick this one up because i
got 40
rounds of ammo
where the rest of the guns here's one
smg
got no ammo first so i'm gonna be stuck
with this guy i guess for 40 rounds
okay let's head out so there's a couple
of cool bits coming up one is the big
this big animation that happens in this
room which i i like quite a lot
it was probably the big wow moment for
me actually when i when i played this
game the first time and the second thing
is that i think we're gonna fight some
of those other time jerks pretty soon
uh
our friend the main antagonist of the
thing littlefinger from game of thrones
and
aidan gillen i believe his name with the
actor lord rathbone from shanghai nights
yes that reference that everyone picks
up on yeah mike exactly two of the
people watching right now oh they're
like oh
rathboner got it yeah you remember see
you remember you know that joke i don't
actually was that a joke yeah owen
wilson says at one point he's like we're
coming for you now rathboner well i'm
not surprised so you're on the same
level as owen wilson now great or
whoever wrote his character my nose is
not as broken though yeah uh okay so
here is an interesting spot i'm gonna
take this brush
fire pistol
here are cronon
canisters you see that chrono canisters
like temporal bombs or something
basically okay what i'm going to do
first of all is this that watch i love
how they kind of realize it's about to
happen right before it happens
do that [ __ ]
and load into this thing
uh-oh it takes a while it takes a while
to destroy these things to be completely
honest
oh crown that i wanted
bulletproof
yeah i think i need to like lay them if
i'm right i think i need to like put the
bomb on it and then
do that
there we go all right
boom boom boom boom like the whole room
yeah the whole room is closing
then you can basically murder anyone you
want so there's a couple of them around
there's another one here
go do it there we go
so then i should probably like sweep up
a bunch of people
i guess it doesn't really hit them then
yeah just wait straight through oh [ __ ]
oh man
bad times
let's turn around this guy shoot him
shoot him
oh
wow i'm a time wizard let's close one
okay there's two more of them here this
isn't this is bad news i need to get the
[ __ ] out of here
see what i mean he's like a little bit
sluggish moving around
i think it's true yeah i think it's
joyce it's slowing down time every two
seconds
i'll use this to get get somewhere else
in a more advantageous position
so slow down time
so it's good for just kind of
positioning yeah get ready maneuvering
around here's some dudes here's some
time [ __ ] boom
oh no
so that's a deal with the two of them
and at least i'm in a better spot
although i should be taking cover a bit
better
shoot that guy so he's down don't have
to worry about the cover and load into
that guy there
so you kind of get used to it you know
you get used to the ebb and flow
of the action
oh oh oh oh where's that last guy
start using the uh powers to like
varying effects
yeah use them
and sort of you find like new
advantageous ways of using them
it's satisfying i like it i can't speak
to how satisfying it is after playing
like more and more and more of this game
if they keep unlocking different ways of
playing it yeah but like it's been a
pretty steady stream of
different mechanics they've been giving
me from the from the off i mean these
cronon chrono
i'm sick of the word crone so much right
now
uh
barrels
chronos in this look at that screen
it's rendering on an atari
all right
let's get where i'll go next
it's got to be something there's always
something probably some sort of time
platforming thing that thing looks out
of place yeah right jesus christ that
looks pretty cool
oh here we go
yeah
i'd be so worried the first time i did
this that it was about to like
murder me that i'd like i phase through
the
steel and then like reappear on the
other side with like steel piercing
through my body you pull a tommy boy and
the that hook hits you in the head yeah
exactly
i'm all over the place with the movie
reference it's good no it's great kids
love them
tommy boy another
popular movie interesting
good time travel movie i guess as far as
those go
there's no time travel on time just no
it's not a very different story taxi
driver is hacking a machine and telling
me about my brother
which makes me feel a little
uncomfortable that he knows all this
information
oh right your brother is uh dominic
monahan yeah my brother's a hobbit yeah
here we go
oh look what car
an electric car the future is great
look in the car this is my brother's car
actually
so i gotta find that what's happening
the door opens that's did i just open
the door with the car that's cool all
right it's like a garage door opener but
just for a normal door yeah look trailer
generator crapped itself hooked up a car
that's pretty cool so i was looking in
the car right there for the briefcase
that my brother was remember i had to go
out and get it yeah and then he got
stolen from me that's right
yeah what's he i haven't seen him in a
while no i guess he's not that is he
said he needed something
there we go bradbury swimming hall
looks like the paddle connected to the
bathroom key we used to have a like
elementary school oh really yeah
that's a bad one
yeah
station they got rid of corporal
punishment had nothing else to do with
the
wooden slabs
nick
here we go
the next steps nothing changes we move
forward university follows a setback we
can use these complications to our
advantage paul is focused on phase three
of the plan he is questioning if there
are traitors within monarch but i'm
confident that he does not know where to
look for them oh
i will make sure to shift the blame
elsewhere the gala is going ahead
tonight
oh i guess is
descent within the ranks you take care
of preparations make sure dr kim's lab
is ready for detonation i'll make sure
the paul is sufficiently distracted
that's to not question our involvement
well there you go it's gonna blow the
lab up there yeah there's collateral
damage left and right just in an email
you know that's secure i was just able
to access it on a random [ __ ]
terminal in in a
in an rv
wi-fi that's running off a generator
yeah
martin and clarence are apparently the
the leaks there you go we figured it out
it's martin hatch martin hatch is the
league
okay so that'll probably change my the
knowledge that i have going into the
next
next
interaction perhaps with
[ __ ] with the antagonist check this out
i'm oddly looking forward to the tv
episode price i was surprised i'm
surprised by the production value of the
first one i don't think we can watch one
yeah i think it's under embargoes all
right maybe that's like what africa
kicks off check this out
time
wizard
happens again roger
all right here we go
it's gonna be a couple of big fights up
here
it's gonna get fun
or it's gonna get crazy
i recognize will's workshop as soon as i
saw the old billboard on top
hey guys
what's going on eat time bubble
wait i'm in the time bubble
i don't know what happened there i think
i just scared them
boom
oh i missed
that one
explosion of cronons i know there's a
so much cronon explosion's happening
look at that love that bit
so satisfying
there is no more unsatisfying murder
than time murder i've said it before and
i'll say it again
yes refill my ammo that means a big
fight's coming i guess
oh hello bunch of these dudes probably
a bunch of these jack officers
let's do that
and get out of there
see how shook he looked
he was like shake oh god hello he
rearranged chronos after all
out of here
use it jack i keep trying to use my my
time
speed thing and it keeps not working
maybe unreal if they
if you damage them and then they just
like
pause to put eye drops in and it heals
them
like an estus flask from dark souls
i need my cronons
that must be like what everyone feels
like when they're they're fighting oh
god damn it's gonna blow up uh when
they're fighting the oh look at that
uh
the the wastelander and fallout is that
they just keep taking stimpaks all the
time and it's like stop it yeah
eat it
i thought that was the last guy that was
going to be good
whoa time slow down see that
income
there's a stutter coming
we've got to be careful whoa slow down
again i love how it does to the music
did you hear that yeah that was that was
really cool
no worries get out away so i can shoot
this red barrel thank you
it's like someone's got a turntable with
this soundtrack yeah
it's like they're playing dj hero
who's next oh this guy hey what's up
see what i mean like trying to shoot
that guy when i was like inside there's
a little bit i mean i probably shouldn't
have gotten down sides but
it still felt a little bit weird
okay here we go oh oh oh oh you're
getting shot right here comes the truck
whoa oh this was one of the demos they
showed oh really yeah i don't know if it
was ether no it was um gamescom
look at this
i mean it's pretty cool yeah
time stutter using it to my advantage
bam
that stings a bit time starter's sting
apparently landed on his ankle
the wrong way
uh-oh what's this
these guys are using technology to be
time wizards they're not pure bloods
like me
they're models they're muggles these are
muggles of the time oh no
oh no
we need like we need like a cronon
version of muggle
like they're cr cruggles
grommets look at these crogg what'd you
say granites yeah grommet i don't know
i like kruggle is that what you said
kruggle yeah these guys are dirty
cruggles
they're mud bloods was what they called
like uh
oh you're rice that's that's what you
call
muggles are just hermione yeah they're
regular so mug bloods yeah so they're
krug bloods yeah all right
yeah
yes i killed that guy
damn it
can i use my
big exploder oh yeah i can oh my god
that's awesome
that's
that's so cool
can i blow up this
cronon thing to like make time go fast
again
whoa
everything's getting real time messed up
here this is all very weird
oh don't mind if i do don't mind if i do
eat it can you shoot that thing is it
looks like that's that backpack that's
giving them the oh yeah can i just go
yeah i think that's what happened to the
other guy i think i like broke his
backpack
right and like phased him back out of
time yeah
his body just didn't know which
dimension to go oh it's messed up he's
getting torn asunder
eat it
yeah look they just sort of like phase
back out
cronon surge
so
i imagine there are going to be fights
later on which are you fighting these
guys in like slow down time and fighting
regular people in
regular time that's what i kind of
i have that's what i'm hoping anyway
yeah it'll be a cool uh
dichotomy or whatever yeah
boom shot that guy through this cement
didn't exist in that dimension
look at this guy
nothing prepared me that's messed up
does that mean he's gonna oh he just
goes back
oh no that's that's for keepsies god
that's so crazy it's trippy i just like
i don't know how this isn't like
breaking the machine like there's some
sort of like
like the coding that's happening here
it's just like
causing endless loops or something
look at that that was a real that was a
real situation we just had there mike
whoa
that guy looks i think i look familiar
ground zero warning sign did we really
need to pop this out no
as if you couldn't read that
sure all right wait what does that say
hold on a second i can't the font's too
small
i have to set it well i can't read it
because there's a big x on it is there
is there some way oh it says absolutely
oh okay okay yeah you can see it there
yeah
ah
sorry
sorry video game creators oh look at
that what
that cool what is this
should he be that surprise at this point
i mean that's pretty messed up it would
be weird yeah that's what happens just
there watching he's gonna jump over
what
see that's what i was interested in with
this game like
already
how that stuff starts happening like in
the movie primer look at this
yeah primer is a really upsetting movie
yeah it's like it's just
it hurts your head
it makes everything feel so
insignificant watch it yeah turn up turn
up the volume here actually because this
part here is super cool
so i'm walking around here
there's no words to describe
will was gone
but
he was all around me
this entire secret life he never talked
about everything he tried to protect me
from
it surrounded me
it's so detailed as well
yeah
trapped in broken time
so i think this isn't building like the
original machine or something his career
obsessing over some failed experiment
that's what he led us to believe
what he built there
it never failed
it works
all right let's keep moving
where do i go over here
need my grand extended another year here
it's a really interesting way of telling
the story as well yeah
it's like having you actually experience
what happened
ew just walk through my
i hope to brother this works
there's the mcguffin
the countermeasure i'm guessing you
spend a lot of time looking for that or
something
to reverse all this
stop the end of
time by all this logic wouldn't it like
the end of time like have already
happened
already happened
is happening it hasn't happened yet
time's a flat circle
boom so like i'm wondering is that stuff
that happens later in the game that we
just saw there or
or has it yeah what happened what is
going to happen
but look at this
i'm just standing here
and it's like just cycling through dana
nice like it's like some it's like some
cry engine
like
like test video it's like so upsetting
there's something like so like unnerving
about just
stop it that'd be awesome if your facial
hair just starts sprouting
his face is like phasing out of this
time bubble i mean there must be cronons
here right there's anywhere there's
cronons this place must be ripe with
them
puberty would be really confusing yeah
it's confusing enough as it is
your voice is different just the next
day
your mom keeps facing in and out of her
old self
you're like what
you're hot oh wait
what very confusing very confusing oh
look
it's the river part rex's
not to be confused with the syracuse
citrus oh man
syracuse citrus in the look at this
building
final four
is overwhelming yeah
every unanswered question i had was
compounded by what i'd seen at that
workshop yeah i mean this is real [ __ ]
up the events of the university were
part of something
much bigger
something that had started 17 years ago
so messed up
leaving ground zero can i press x on
this sign so i can read it back
well there's no option on that one
get to the dry dock i'm almost there
ah
gotta
look at that guy's picture oh now i
remember that guy
charlie charlie winkers
oh and remember jack joyce that guy you
were supposed to have apprehended yeah
he's still shooting his way through the
entire operation get your [ __ ] together
he didn't put a full stop after your get
your [ __ ] together all right
yeah your [ __ ] was just a package deal
comes together
here we go it comes together
monarch
i'm facing through time and saying the
same thing over and over again
look at this guy hey what's up dylan
holt
no i think i'll use shoddy on you
death
there's something wrong
it was excessive even for dying yeah
that elongated scream was
that's cause he was actually screaming
there for like millennia was it just
time travel we just saw a little window
into it
i think so many narrative objects right
now he's been screaming for years
william joyce is dead ah our only shot
at stopping this thing is jack
but if i stop time i'll be able to get
william back right or maybe go back in
time and get william to help me i don't
know what's going on
i will contact you once i'm on the other
side
other side of what
these doors are taking a while to open
efficiency and monarch would be
increased
20 percent if they just made those doors
open a bit faster is there any cronons
over here
croutons
time croutons
in this delicious time soup do you have
enough to
rank up right now no i don't think so
let me check
whoa
i don't honestly nowhere to do that
probably here
timeline
diaries and upgrades there we go look
it's serene
and jack and beth i can watch all these
diaries kind of let you know how many
diaries are going to be look at that
eight diaries left with paul serene
less so would will i guess he's not in
the movie as much
or a game i forget what we're doing here
purchase i've got one i can increase my
focus on time dodge
time vision using time dodge will time
rush
the word time is used
quite a lot in this game temporarily
reveal enemy positions time blast
increased blast radius i'd love that but
it's uh it's going to cost me two so i'm
just going to hold on to that
no more time croutons here
all right it's got to tap it that's the
problem i keep i keep holding it i just
got tap it and then hold left trigger to
slow down afterwards yeah
jack got a phone call you have to
understand that will force my hand oh my
god it's full serene on the on the
the blower
is that what you call it sure
the blower the blower
i've never heard that it's on the old
blower
time's ending and you're having a
[ __ ] party
because when time ends
it's gonna read this email while i'm on
the phone
that was an extensive psych evaluation
yeah well i guess they usually are
what's this all for
goodbye jack
frustrating phone calls
he just follows up with the text saying
lol
lol jk
sorry about time
green zone can i press x on this
strong headache dizziness or nausea loss
of memory
yeah yikes let's go in
to be like a fourth one like
reappearing as your younger self
multiple personality disorder
seeing yourself through time ending of
time destruction of time what gun do i
have
i mean this probably isn't the best gun
right tactical smg i could probably
upgrade
to a hot
oh no i guess not
all these headsets these hot bluetooth
headsets
i think they got any gunners here
got time gas masks
wow those things are really resilient
yeah the assault rifle right i should
probably get this all right it's only
got 60 rounds though
vector next oh look at this one
yeah this yeah no i do want this one
don't they
tactical smg
all right we're good
let's have what i assume is a fight
oh i think we're nearing the end of our
playthrough actually
this is the green zone
this is the green zone
this is the uh
the dark side doesn't sound threatening
look at him
use the time power
yeah use a time bubble to stop the
rotors or
oh what
oh paul serene ain't [ __ ] around he's
like i can break chains too
yeah that's like having a wand in one
hand and a gun in the other and shooting
the gun
that's exactly what it's like
boom wow that was really well done by
him
like a big
lethal rube goldberg machine wow i'm
surprised he
managed to survive that fall
his eyes are a little bit dead sometimes
the actors the eyes are always the
problem in these it looks super look at
this though this is dope
oh yeah i'm not reviewing the game up
peter brown is
asking oh [ __ ] that'll go up one jesus a
week or two come on
yeah i think so like a week's time yeah
we've had this game for a little while
now that's not how i do this how do i do
this whoa is that
like alice in wonderland it looks like
or like willy wonka looks like you're
getting smaller as you're going look at
this
yeah
my time powers are increasing
it's like lifting the x-wing out of the
swamp i'm getting my little point
or maybe help
it's going to fall over again oh jeez
louise
whoa
that was whoa
yikes
oh
that would be really disconcerting
yeah i mean all this would this would
all be very upsetting you're right
the time i didn't think he had much
worse where am i going next over there
okay
i've actually never gotten past this so
this is the first i've gotten there
can i stand here
jesus christ this is her
oh my god
thanks for the arrow who drew the arrows
maybe i'll find out later yourself came
back probably right that's probably what
happened who knows
what do i do now oh oh oh
you look fine oh no
late reaction that is an appropriate
response to what just happened yeah
that's pretty cool
yeah i thought exactly i
almost i don't know what's going on
it's like a time maze very dangerous
maze
that's why this game is called dangerous
time maze yeah
oh my goodness
so this is like the shooting is like
fine right it like reminds me of like
lots of games where the shooting is like
fine like i'm not blown away about like
i feel the same way that game's like two
writers where i'm like yeah it's like
moment-to-moment action is like all
right it's not like i've never played
anything like this before but the sort
of the main reason i want to keep
playing jesus christ
is because of this stuff i'm kind of
because of the television show as well
but i'm not sure if that gets
boring after a while oh
orange time wizards damn it
what the hell this wheel of cheese
what's happening
giant gouda rolling at you
good bye
what's going on is that still happening
behind me
oh my god it's like going backwards and
forwards
eat it
oh these guys aren't time wizards
they're just
scientists that's all right
oh no oh no
oh i got covered in some sort of time
candy
what's happening behind me
oh what the hell oh my god are you like
timed this whole thing i have no idea
what's happening it's freaking me out
these guys are back oh man
what is going
on eat it
eat it
look at this thing it keeps falling over
it's freaking me out it's like fall on
us any second
okay this is the coolest thing i've seen
in the game so far
eat it
damn it
i get to use this thing again
i haven't even using my time bubble
at all no this time around i need to
kind of hard to concentrate when that
giant barge is about to fall i know it's
like super upsetting it's just
constantly there
eat it oh god i keep it that is awful i
just miss that guy completely
you eat it look at this jerk
you can eat cronons or whatever
man
like i can't wait to see what this looks
like on pc because this looks real good
on xbox one yeah definitely like an xbox
one is
the machine usually where you start to
see a lot of rough edges
at least if you're used to playing games
on pc which i like i predominantly play
games on pc now so sure but this is like
this looks great yeah it does
oh my goodness don't die don't die don't
die don't they fly bubble
what does wood sponge
rice
what the [ __ ] is happening
look at this nonsense
i don't think anyone knows what's going
on
these guys are like what they're gonna
start shooting each other we didn't
train for this
he must be dead oh yeah there we go
see the last one yeah i love how he just
stands there like that's his death
how would you bury him
somewhere
he's just stuck there forever
they're lowering him into the grave and
it's an open casket funeral and he's
still doing that they're just taking
temporal real estate like this whole
area is just full of dead bodies and
people just have to like get used to it
they're just stuck there they're just
stuck in time forever yeah so they build
like shopping malls around all these
people and it's like
this thing is so good look at this this
is so cool
imagine your mom showing up at your
funeral and just seeing you and be like
okay i can't i'm gonna leave
how does your brain work mike
i don't know i'm just i'm like thinking
ahead i like it
yeah thinking ahead is that time guy
i don't think so
i've got a few though but
well there's not much time left for time
gags if i'm being completely honest i
think we're nearing the end of this uh
africa is on its way i think so i don't
think we're i'd show africa i don't
think i think
africa happens in the cutscene we're not
led show i think
it sounds like we're talking about like
a setting you're going to go to but no
it's actually the song by toto yes it is
the the
tell me if you've heard this toto song
before of all the total songs yeah i
think it's when we go up this ladder
okay i think we have to stop so
hopefully africa starts playing
immediately
up the big ladder up this big lad i'm
guessing that is going to fall down yeah
what was she doing this whole time
oh it's chilling out
time to start there we go
what if i don't trust you
then shoot me
oh okay okay how about i just steal your
gun everything there's that creep in the
back
oh
that's pretty good
so i think we have to stop after this
cutscene okay
and thanks by the way for the plus one
in the back seat
hey
that's interesting that means he's gonna
we're gonna have him for the for more of
the game okay
which is very interesting
because otherwise it would have been
oh turn it off turn it up
set it up
okay hurry boy she's waiting
there's nothing instead of harmony
quantum break folks
with that hot little number just sign
off
thank you so much for watching
our weekly show
here okay spot.com every week for the
rest of the year me and mike are gonna
sit down on monday morning and play some
time wizards
uh this game is eventually gonna come
out um let me check the days i did have
to date my head earlier on but i can't
remember now i think it's i think it's i
think it's april like 15th i don't
actually think it is next week yeah
because you know
ratchet and dark souls are just 12.
let's shut her up for a second sorry
what say ratchet and clank and dark
souls 3 are both the 12th i know that
for sure right um it's a bunch of games
quantum break is that april 5th okay
there you go it is out
i believe that is next tuesday
yeah
that is next tuesday april 5th our
review will be up on gamespot.com and
then we'll be able
next week's stream well monday well
actually i'm not i think we get to do
chapter three monday yeah i think okay
and then tuesday we play the whole game
cool just watch all the tv shows sing
all the totals africa
have a great time yeah i'm gonna go
listen that song right now yeah it'd be
great you do too uh we'll be back
tomorrow on the lobby on gamespot.com
and twitch.tv forward slash game spot 2
p.m pacific uh there's probably a bunch
of dark souls streams happening this
week as well i imagine mary kish and
eric tay will be all over that uh and a
bunch of more stuff happening right here
on our live streaming channel and also
on gamespot.com what are you working on
uh
dark souls nice um i had a drift review
oh you wanted five out of ten yeah
uh yeah i mean play that game if you
want it's a pretty good story good well
written but takes a lot of frustration
to get to it very linear very
yeah scripted
pretty uh they've like the survival
aspects are kind of forced it's just
slow it's good
control is pretty floaty in that as well
yeah yep
they're floaty controls for sure yeah i
think you took any joke that it was
going to be made about sorry i don't
know it's fine because it's in space
yeah and then dark souls review goes up
monday i'll be streaming battleborn with
aaron wednesday cool new story missions
are dropping awesome and uh our review
of the oculus rift is also yeah live on
gameswell.com uh so check that out as
well drift better on oculus yes it
doesn't obviously doesn't look as good
it's really gorgeous you pay six hundred
dollars does it get a six at a time
yeah i guess so there you go there you
go unofficial thank you so much for
hanging out as ever folks we will be
back right here on twitter tv for just
getting swat throughout the week and in
the meantime check out gamespot.com for
all the latest in video game news and
also entertainment on other things as
well see you next time hope you have a
nice easter if you're in europe enjoy
your day off if you're in america
enjoy your their work bye